[Music]
dialogue on your show I would think must
be very tricky because the producers and
the writers are sticklers for yeah it's
pretty exactitude about physics and
chemistry
it doesn't matter see that reason
exactly I mean you can't I wouldn't know
where to begin improv on that topic you
know any of the topics even comic books
I don't know how to riff on that yeah so
they they they they they they came up
with one thing where they wanted Sheldon
to sing the periodic table or the
element song the element song literally
one of the worst moments of my life was
trying to win it I'm not kidding I
thought I like memorizing I enjoy
working on the dialogue that was
loony-bin territory where I thought I
was screaming around the house and I
don't remember
I couldn't we shot an episode last night
I couldn't tell you one line from it in
and out that song I don't remember all
of it but that will not it's like a war
wound it will not go as antimony arsenic
aluminum selenium and hydrogen and
oxygen nitrogen and rhenium and nickel
nikka nickel neodymium neptunium
germanium and iron americium yuri theum
uranium I don't know I don't know what
those words mean
[Applause]
I know what I own is an aluminum is
right germanium neodymium what's that a
wreath um is the white yeah yeah yuria
man I know there's no uranium occurs in
your bladder there was something yeah
that word stroke keeps coming to my head
the whole interview oh really
no that's not what he said what do you
say what do the kids say in the video I
sound like a pervert the perverted kid
about the goose I want to know your fall
out of me you're fine
Oh barely this is amazing you can
remember that but you know what I
remember I was in I was cast as Santa
Claus in my second grade play we had
behind I had to once I had the height
for it didn't use Yeah right
I don't know why I was cast but they had
me memorize this long thing and I
remembered pacing up and down outside
the the Baldwin School in Brookline mass
remember my lines and the thing is to
this day remember it at the age of 77
I remember the speech that I had you
give good yeah what is it now saying it
it was Santa Claus going over the list
of everything he had to know and it was
of everything that he gives kids
bicycles tricycles dump truck toys
cowboy outfits for a million boys jump
ropes jackstones dolls with curls sets
the dishes for a million girls books for
the book as you sit and read baseball
mitts for the baseball breed candy for
the sweet tooth chess for the clever
it's just as it's been forever and ever
[Applause]
[Music]
second place just a little I expect
something yeah I've always sighs and all
these years of doing television I've
always thought at some point I'm gonna
completely run out of things to say I'll
be talking to and I'll Robert in yer and
I'll just go did what